welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and spider-man no way home revealed
new details and visuals from empire
magazine with mysterious cameos
described by tom holland and the
director framing the movie as spider-man
end game which isn't really new for us
everything since 2019 has been whatever
end game one division in game loki
endgame eternals and game dc movie and
games quick game in game endgame is now
just code for epic jack mates and make a
scream like goats i'm gonna break down
all the new clues we learned from the
set images these interesting quotes and
easter eggs that are hidden in the
empire covers but the first image we
gotta talk about is this shot of peter
parker suited up in the iron spider
armor fleeing from alfred molina as doc
ock now we saw brief clips of this in
the first trailer that dropped back in
august
hello peter
now it is fair to assume that this
moment might have been edited out of
context for the trailer and might not
reflect how this scene will go down in
the film and this photo does seem a bit
staged like peter is running away from
doc ock with that green george
washington bridge sign behind them both
whereas in the trailer shot the editing
made it look like peter was reacting to
doc ock by activating the armor with the
green sign behind only peter in this
angle but there are some interesting
clues if you look closely at the
vehicles on that bridge like the black
suv directly behind peter as he's
running toward us that same suv can be
seen off to the right earlier in the
trailer and then in another shot it
looks damaged from the back with the
backseat right door left open as the
green goblin pumpkin grenade explodes
behind the sign and then this is also
the same car that peter looks into the
backseat window at actress paula newsom
who i have speculated could be some
authority figure whose opinion of peter
or peter is trying to chain and went
over which of course would give him even
more reason to pull this woman out of
the car thus leaving that door open as
doc and green goblin are attacking this
bridge also in this photo doc ock is
lifting this blue sedan which looks like
the same blue vw that i pointed out in a
previous video bears the license plate
of 1963 o3 of course an easter egg to
the amazing spider-man number 3 in 1963
peter's famous first encounter with dr
octopus as this moment and this slung vw
were for our mcu peter parker now moving
on to the other photo it shows peter
unmasked in a black and red suit
clinging to some surface with the ring
plate off to the right that has a row of
slots in it this does look a bit like
the circular window frame of the boat
house where doc och constructed his
fusion device in 2004 spider-man 2. that
window in most of the boathouse ended up
getting sucked into the fusion reaction
as doc and toby mcguire peter's fight
went on but it's possible that part of
doc ock's reality warped teleportation
into tom holland peter's universe could
have been through this fusion reaction
with doctor strange's spell and peter's
tampering with it reacting with that
fusion reaction to open a portal through
which doc ock would travel and arrive in
the mcu but from his perspective it
might just look like the golden glow
from that fusion spreading all over the
boathouse changing everything from night
to day warping his reality and leaving
him bloating in the hudson of the mcu if
you think about it when venom and eddie
brock warped realities from their
universe to the mcu a similar golden
glow shone in from outside and this warp
might also drag in some elements from
doc ock's native universe like chunks of
the architecture of the boathouse and
doc cox fusion tech which is what peter
now finds himself on in this photo now
moving on to the cover art empire used
for this issue spider-man is shown in a
new suit that looks like a cross between
his red and black suit from far from
home and the gold trimming from his iron
spider armor but with the black fabric
from his black and gold look that we've
been seeing all over the promotional
material that black and gold suit might
just actually be peter's red and black
suit turned inside out but here the suit
is a fusion of all the multiple versions
which could be a clue pointing to how
peter will have to fuse multiple
versions of himself joined forces with
his variants to conquer this new
multiversal crisis and we get glimpses
of that here the arm of doc ock the
green goblin pumpkin grenade some bolts
of electricity probably from electro
while below one of the golden runic
bands doctor strange used to warp
reality for the spell orbits peter and
above the background is all textured
into a kaleidoscopy prism much like the
way the multiverse was depicted in what
if now look folks we are coming up on
halloween and if you want to embrace the
scary season without leaving behind your
nerdy roots our partners at epic hero
shop have a great shirt for you it's
called empire of darkness and it's a fun
mashup design with a chainsaw wielding
mando standing atop a pile of undead
stormtroopers in the style of the army
of darkness movie poster their shirt
inspired by venom 2 symbiotic chaos is
really cool and probably qualifies as
halloween appropriate but like the shirt
i'm wearing they got a wide variety of
shirts and hoodies stickers and other
merch inspired by all of your favorite
properties like loki spider-man suicide
squad shang-chi there's also official
new rockstars merch with our logo so you
can watch our videos in style and while
you're checking out the merch subscribe
to the newsletter so that you can stay
up to date on the upcoming new releases
for the holiday season which will
include the return of some fan favorites
as well as some previously pruned
variants check it all out at
epicheroshop.com
you'll be helping out our channel while
also earning some major nerd cred now
empire magazine also released an
alternate cover that is filled with
easter eggs on this version we see all
four of doc ock's arms as well as a
goblin pumpkin grenade a yellow
lightning bolt on a green background of
course electro but his original colors
and then a fist of sand for sandman who
we saw showing up in the trailer and
it's rising up from this green and black
striped fluid the colors of flint
marco's classic shirt there's also a
blue globe which could be the fishbowl
helmet of mysterio now obviously it was
quentin beck's machinations that led to
peter getting exposed and ruining his
life but mysterio may or may not appear
in the flesh and no way home the movie
is already pretty crowded but i for one
remain skeptical that he actually died
in london you'll notice there are two
versions of the spyder logo on the cover
to the left there's the parenthetical
leg design that we've seen mostly in the
mcu but then at the bottom there's a
more old-school version and that's right
beside dr strange's seal of vishanti
that's contained within an eye shape
like the eye of agamotto necklace and
you'll notice it has a green center like
where the green time stone would be
however one unexplained detail so far
from no way home is why doctor strange
is wearing that necklace if the time
stone is supposed to have been atomized
at this point and the necklace itself
was crushed by thanos infinity war well
as i pointed out in my past 12 more
details video that came out a couple
weeks ago there remains a very good
chance that doctor strange's odd
behavior in this movie is because he's
being manipulated by someone who knowing
what lies ahead in doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness could be the
scarlet witch now you'll notice at the
center of this cover are several runic
rings like the ones in dr strange's
spell three layers of text perhaps
referring to the three spider universes
that get collided in this movie the
middle ring just reads the words no way
home over and over again the letters
stitched together from nodes like a
spiderweb and the ring closest to the
center shows the manhattan skyline
bending on itself as we see the city do
in the trailer as its reality warps and
peter falls into that hole which makes
it interesting how in this donut hole
there is a series of spider-man heads
layered upon each other coming out of it
now these bear that 60s retro design
that is really reflected in all the art
on this cover but the fact that we see
several spider heads layered on top of
each other i just think is a pretty
interesting clue that we will probably
see multiple spider-man variants
arriving in this universe from
inter-dimensional portals now director
john watts calling this spider-man end
game yeah it's got to be a reference to
endgame's portal sequence where captain
america got a whole bunch of backup that
brought us all to our feet and in this
case in spiderman no way home the one
thing that's gonna get us to our feet is
tom holland peter parker receiving
backup from the other peter parkers
we've been dying to see coming up on his
left and on his right now tom holland
also dropped some hints about a scene
with peter aunt may happy hogan and a
fourth mystery guest all sitting around
a table talking about what it's like to
be a superhero that made tom holland and
his brother's jaws drop
so this mystery figure could be toby
maguire peter or andrew garfield peter
charlie cox matt murdock tom hardy eddie
brock maybe whoever the new uncle ben of
this reality will be we're gonna go more
into this mystery and tomorrow's episode
of inside marvel be sure to check it out
but meantime let me know who you think
holland was referring to for this scene
you can support new rockstars by
checking out our merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos follow
new rockstars and subscribe for
breakdowns of everything you love thanks
for watching
[Music]
you